[Música]
[Aplausos]
llegó un lunes al camarín donde
concentramos para el show de la bomba de
tiempo había mucho movimiento algunos de
mis compañeros conversaban otros
entraban en calor tocando sus
instrumentos y siempre están lo que les
encanta jugar al ping-pong
yo venía de un día muy largo estaba
realmente cansado así que lo primero que
hice al entrar fue fijaron el pizarrón a
ver si tenía que dirigir
y efectivamente al 1er
en ese momento pensé en ir a decirle al
coordinador de directores de que no
estaba para abrir el show
pero si ya lo he hecho mil veces y sabe
que contaba con un grupo de 15
percusionistas tremendos apoya fallar me
quedé tranquilo
sube el escenario
improvisa
[Música]
i
créanme que esa noche tuvimos una gran
improvisación pero no fue magia estoy
convencido de que la improvisación se
mete en nuestras vidas todo el tiempo de
una forma muy cotidiana incluso podría
decirles que improvisamos sin darnos
cuenta
como cuando pasa algo que nos cambia los
planes del día
cuando te cae alguien de sorpresa a
cenar o cuando se pierde la señal del
gps
todos improvisamos
por eso me gustaría ver cómo están
ustedes para improvisar
el alma de tiempo tenemos una seña que
se llama aporte libre que es ésta
significa dame tu idea tu ritmo así que
cuando se les haga esta seña ustedes se
van a improvisar algo lo que sea lo que
se les ocurra está listos
[Aplausos]
felicito a quien se animó a hacer algún
tipo de sonido y el que no le tengo que
decir algo utilizó un gran recurso el
silencio
pero podríamos agregarle algo más vamos
aquí y lo vamos a espacio yo les aseguro
que sobre el final de la charla vamos a
terminar sonando juntos entonces hasta
ahora lo que tenemos son resultados muy
dispares a la hora de improvisar
entonces les pregunto ustedes creen que
podemos improvisar sin parecer unos
improvisados que hacemos todo así nomás
podemos improvisar y que el resultado se
acerque lo más posible a lo que
esperamos podemos aprender a improvisar
en la bomba creemos que sí por eso ahora
les voy a pasar un par de señas de las
que utiliza como director y vamos a ver
la diferencia con lo que pasó recién
está listos
primera seña nota corta o staccato se
muestra y se ejecuta como la van a
ejecutar a ustedes con un sonido de
palmas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
y qué pasa si yo señaló aquel sector
perfecto y este sector
genial
[Aplausos]
la mano bien vamos a poco
nota larga
yo como la tengo yo
ustedes
divina a ver
tremendo tremendo super
como estamos viendo entonces hay más
cosas en juego a la hora de improvisar
pero que es improvisar
el diccionario dice que improvisar es
hacer algo sin estudio en mi preparación
previa también suele decirse que pensar
una acción y ejecutarla de forma
simultánea
en la bomba creemos que improvisar es a
la vez conocimiento y no conocimiento
suena contradictorio pero no lo es nos
referimos al conocimiento del arte
musical y al no conocimiento de lo que
va a ocurrir en el escenario
reflexionamos un poquito sobre esto
la improvisación es el conocimiento del
arte musical creo que todos estamos de
acuerdo en que el conocimiento es el
punto de partida de cualquier acción
incluso el estudio la práctica la
preparación y con el tiempo la
experiencia en la impro que hice en el
comienzo de la charla yo necesité de
varios conocimientos previos para poder
ordenar los sonidos mezclarlos jugar y
finalmente improvisar
cuando decimos que la improvisación es a
la vez el no conocimiento de lo que va a
ocurrir en el escenario nos referimos a
que nunca vamos a saber lo que va a
pasar en el momento
si yo quisiera volver a ser exactamente
igual la misma impro ya les digo que
aunque utilicen los mismos sonidos no me
va a salir igual y esto es crucial
porque muchos creen que lo que se
necesita para estar arriba del escenario
es talento que con eso basta
nosotros creemos que mucho más que eso
son muchas horas de estudio y de
práctica para aprovecharlas y volcarlas
a la improvisación a lo que no conocemos
reorganizando todo y creando algo
novedoso que es lo que en el grupo
definimos como el sonido de bomba
por ejemplo
levante la mano a ver quién pintó con
témperas alguna vez
creo que todos lo hicimos cuando fuimos
chicos primero nos enseñaron para qué
servía la hoja de papel en blanco
el pincel las témperas los colores y
después nos dieron toda esa información
y nos dejaron crear que hicimos nosotros
garabatos de color marrón como mezcla de
todos los demás colores incluso de tanto
que le dimos a agujero una hoja
entonces lo que se me ocurre ahora es
que les voy a mostrar algunos colores
más y vamos a ver que podemos pintar
vamos
repasemos las señas primero yo creo que
se van a acordar
[Aplausos]
genial
lo que quería decir es separan por favor
muchas gracias
un colorcito nuevo fíjense esta seña se
llama pregunta respuesta yo pregunto
tocó una frase todos ustedes responden
con la misma más
ustedes
[Aplausos]
como yo
antes
ah
o
ustedes
y
ah
[Aplausos]
efecto tremendo 15 15 paradas
no
qué pasa qué pasa si éste estaría bueno
que repitan eso sí para que la música no
se corte entonces yo les voy a hacer así
sigan está voy
ah
ok yo me voy a tomar un café a la misma
hora y tiene que estar haciendo
exactamente esto hasta que yo venga
[Aplausos]
y corte
está mezclemos los colores atentos
[Aplausos]
bien
y
ah
[Aplausos]
gracias
ahí está el ejercicio otra vez
[Aplausos]
final
tú a quien quinta final efecto tremendo
[Aplausos]
estamos muy bien se viene algo grande
pero antes quisiera asegurarme de que
van a poder trasladar a sus vidas el
secreto de la bomba para que puedan
actuar en tiempo real e improvisar en el
aquí y ahora para eso tengo algo muy
importante que decirles y es algo que
estuvo frente a nuestras narices todo el
tiempo y es que todos podemos improvisar
conociendo nuestras propias capacidades
los recursos con los cuales contamos y
el lugar que ocupamos
en la bomba de tiempo los músicos
tenemos la capacidad de interpretar y
ejecutar en tiempo real un sistema de
más de 90 señas creadas por nuestro
primer director santiago vázquez también
tenemos nuestras propias capacidades y
nuestra formación
en el grupo contamos con un montón de
recursos el escenario las luces el
sonido los instrumentos los palos para
tocar
el usuario
pero además de conocer nuestras
capacidades y nuestros recursos
tenemos que saber el lugar que ocupamos
es decir las pautas que son ciertas
condiciones que vamos a tener que
respetar muy necesarias para canalizar
toda la creatividad que ponemos en juego
a la hora de improvisar
cuáles son las pautas en la bomba
sabemos cuánto va a durar un show
cuántos directores va a haber cuánto
tiempo va a dirigir cada uno cuantos
músicos va a ver cómo son las rotaciones
internas
a parte de un montón de reglas musicales
que nos van a hacer tocar juntos como
grupo y en armonía
entonces vamos a repasar los tres
elementos principales para que una
improvisación funcione
una capacidad es evalúa que puedes hacer
y que no reconoce tus fortalezas y tus
debilidades se acaban de dar cuenta que
ustedes también tienen la capacidad de
interpretar y ejecutar las señas
dos recursos asegúrense en cualquier
momento de sus vidas a identificar esa
hoja de papel en blanco ese pincel
esas témperas esos colores que van a
tener disponibles a la hora de
improvisar
que redescubrieron hoy
un gran recurso su cuerpo y siendo
sonidos con los pies con las palmas y
con sus voces
tres pautas asegúrate de detectar las
reglas a cumplir cuando te llegue el
momento de improvisar
cuáles van a ser las pautas
que confíen en mí yo soy su director
ustedes son mis músicos así que
cuando yo les haga la seña ustedes las
ejecutan
permítanme decirles algo antes de
terminar
la improvisación es conocimiento porque
articulamos elementos conocidos y es no
conocimiento porque nunca vamos a saber
cómo van a estar dispuestos es
aprovechar algo que viene del pasado con
la intención de llegar a un lugar nuevo
en el futuro actuando en el aquí y ahora
así que ya conocen algunas señas
los invito y las invito a los
desconocidos
improvisamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]